the NBA comes under fire for cowering to
the brutal regime of communist China but
the problem runs way deeper than the NBA
infecting virtually all of Corporate
America Hollywood and even the US
government we will examine the root
cause of the trouble the eternal Maxim
he who pays the piper calls the tune
then Matt Lauer is accused of violent
rape but is the me2 movement redefining
rape beyond the bounds of Reason we will
analyze as it were the evidence finally
the mailbag all that and more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
this NBA issue is so much bigger than
the NBA you've probably heard about the
NBA issue I've been kind of avoiding the
story all week because I don't care
about the NBA I don't care about most
professional sports leagues I really
only watch baseball and even that not
that often so I've been kind of out of
it all of these names are new to me the
issue is not new to me the issue is will
American entities bow down to China for
that most-holy dollar will they give up
their integrity give up their principles
give up everything they believed in for
Mammon that's what it really comes down
to and every step of the way in this NBA
issue has been so pathetic but it's not
just the NBA so what happened with the
NBA the NBA issue all began when Daryl
Morey of the Houston Rockets tweeted out
seven words just a seven word tweet
fight for freedom stand with Hong Kong
in the context of this is that the
Communist Chinese government is clamping
down on Hong Kong which is a politically
independent entity it was controlled by
the British for a hundred years and then
the British in a moment of stupidity and
weakness in the 1990s decided to give
Hong Kong back to China and everything
has gone downhill since because China is
one of the worst regimes in the history
of the world and the West never should
have given them back Hong Kong and now
we are where we are which is that the
brutal Chinese government is going in
and clamping down on protesters because
the they've they've increasingly tried
to take political control away from Hong
Kong over the past two decades and they
passed a new law which would allow them
to extradite prisoners from Hong Kong so
political dissidents for instance they
could just go into Hong Kong and rip
them back to mainland China China
protested that now they're clamping down
one person has been been shot already a
lot of lot of chaos in the streets so in
the midst of all this I mean this has
been going on for weeks and weeks now
Daryl Morey comes out and says fight for
freedom stand with Hong Kong China
didn't like that very much the Chinese
consulate
Houston expressed quote strong
dissatisfaction with Morrie's tweet okay
well I got your dissatisfaction right
here who cares what the Chinese
government says right except the NBA
makes a lot of money in China
NBA has a lot of relationships in China
you sure that's what you want to say mr.
Mori are you sure
maybe we should and this is how it
starts this is how the censorship starts
and it infects every level of the
government so after he makes his
comments all of a sudden there's a
sportswear brand Li Ning they sponsor
some NBA players they announced they
would suspend business ties with the NBA
okay that's fine that's just one that's
just one hit
then $0.10 which is the NBA's exclusive
digital partner in China said it would
suspend business relations with the
Rockets so no more digital passes in
China to the Rockets the fans who bought
the team passed to watch the Rockets
this season would just have to choose a
different team which is obviously not
how sports works you want to watch your
team you don't want to watch a different
team but that's what's happened then the
Chinese Basketball Association canceled
exhibition games with the NBA affiliates
of both the Rockets and the Mavericks
later this month
the Lakers Nets exhibition game in
Shanghai did occur on Thursday but it
was played without sponsors media
sessions for the teams were canceled so
no money no publicity for at no point
and the Yahoo Sports was reporting
several NBA teams were now planning for
a scenario in which the cap for the 2020
2021 season could drop between 10 and 15
percent because of the situation with
the NBA in China a lot of basketball
fans in China a lot of people in China
in general a lot more of this sportswear
brand anta which works with a few NBA
players announced that it would suspend
contract renewal talks with the NBA so
they're going to lose money they're an
NBA Cares event in Shanghai was canceled
by the Chinese Board of Education China
is basically saying if you don't shut up
about our vicious evil political
activities we're gonna cut you off we're
gonna cut you off from your money so
how does the NBA respond this is a good
American sports league they're being
bullied by an adversary of the United
States a red Communist disgusting
despicable government they're gonna
stand up to them right no they're not
they're gonna just beg for money
NBA sends that an official statement
quote we recognize that the views
expressed by Houston Rockets general
manager Daryl Morey have deeply offended
many of our friends and fans in China
which is regrettable while Daryl has
made it clear that his tweet does not
represent the Rockets or the NBA the
values of the league support individuals
educating themselves and sharing their
views on matters important to them we
have great respect for the history and
culture of China and hope that sports in
the NBA can be used as a unifying force
to bridge cultural divides and bring
people together sorry what a disgusting
weaselly horrific there is not one
redeeming syllable in that entire
statement because it's not that they
have respect for the people of China if
they had respect for the people of China
they'd support the overthrow of their
brutal regime they don't and they
obviously don't have respect for their
own country the United States but they
have respect for is the almighty dollar
and so they send out this tweet saying
we would never support freedom why would
we want to fight for freedom where the
NBA why would we want to fight for
freedom we're an American sports league
they send that out it wasn't just the
NBA
Houston's team owner Tillman Fertitta am
i pronouncing that right I don't really
care sent out a tweet acknowledging that
Morrie's opinions do not reflect the
views of the Houston Rockets he said
quote listen Maury does not speak for
the Houston Rockets our presence in
Tokyo is all about the promotion of NBA
internationally we are not a political
organization at ESPN well you are a
political organization you're supporting
Communist China right you are political
there you are making a political
statement the political statement is we
oppose the Pro freedom protesters in
Hong Kong we oppose one of the last
bright spots around China and we support
the brutal communist regime and what
happens then for Daryl Morey he could
either stand firm hold his ground
and I will tell you it's very important
to do that when the outraged mob comes
for you very important to hold your
ground if you haven't said anything
wrong maybe if you said something right
and important so what does daryl morey
do he caves he sends that an apology
quote I did not intend my tweets to
cause any offense to rockets fans and
friends of mine in China I was merely
voicing one thought based on one
interpretation of one complicated event
I've had a lot of opportunities since
that tweet to hear and consider other
perspectives you know like of our brutal
slave masters in China who control us
because they control all of our money
I have also pretty I added that part he
didn't put that in the statement he goes
on I have always appreciated the
significant support our Chinese fans and
sponsors have provided and I would hope
that those who are upset will know that
offending or misunderstanding them was
not my intention those who are upset by
the way our Communist slave masters in
China so he doesn't want them I'm sorry
I didn't understand you you brutal
degenerate communists he goes on my
tweets are my own and in no way
represent the Rockets or the NBA we know
that we know it because the NBA sucks up
to China our adversary because they have
no care for their country they have no
care for principles they have no care
for the people fighting for freedom in
Hong Kong we know we know that the NBA
does not agree with your tweets not only
do we get that apology we get an apology
from the rocket star James Harden who
said quote we apologize we love China we
love playing here for both of us
individually we go there once or twice a
year and they show us the most support
and love we appreciate them as a fanbase
and we love everything they're about
especially communism they didn't say
that but that's the implication that's
the only conclusion you could draw from
is it's common we appreciate the support
they give us individually and as an
organization how how pathetic and it's
not just that they're cowering to China
it's not just that the league is
cowering to China they're shutting down
freedom of the press in China in in the
NBA to suck up to China the rot runs so
much deeper but it goes all the way up
to the president the United States we'll
get to that in a second but first I have
to thank our friends over at prey
dot-com
prayer is very important and nobody
takes the time to pray very few people
do even religious people doing
practicing religious people rarely take
the time to pray because they've got so
much Instagram to scroll through or so
they've got so many more important
things than speaking to God so we are
now partnering with pray calm the number
one app for prayer and sleep both
anxiety and sleep deficiency can do
serious damage to your brain and your
body high stress and lack of sleep make
you more prone to accidents weight gain
and depression with pray calm you'll
discover a new daily and nightly prayer
routine as well as inspirational Bible
stories designed to strengthen your
faith and lift your spirit pray calm
gives you motivational daily prayer
plans private and inclusive prayer
communities and relaxing bedtime Bible
stories that will help you fall asleep
here the bible come to life through
stories like Adam and Eve Noah and the
Ark and the Ten Commandments as part of
your daily prayer routine on pray calm
prayer is so important I can all joking
aside prayer is so incredibly important
and I've found I go off the rails if I
don't pray regularly it's so important
so use pray calm to build a healthy
habit of Prayer gain wisdom from the
Bible and fall asleep to bedtime Bible
stories right now Michael knows
listeners get 40 percent off a pray calm
Premium Subscription by downloading the
pray comm app pray calm / Knolls kinder
wles that is pra why.com / knowles can
wles
over 50 million prayers have been
created on pray comm find out why pray
calm / Knolls
obviously this NBA issue has generated a
lot of controversy some some reporters
have been asking about it are they
taking the questions are they giving
serious answers no the people working
for the NBA are now shutting down the
very reporters themselves so that they
don't need to answer for their
disgusting behavior hi Christina
MacFarlane CNN and the NBA has always
been a league that prides itself when
it's clear in its coaches being able to
speak out openly about political and
societal affairs I just wonder after the
events of this week and the fallout
we've seen whether you would both feel
differently about speaking out
that way in the future it's a legitimate
question this is an event that's
happened this week during during the NBA
this particular question has not been
answered James you can't ask any
questions here this is a press
conference it's amazing how quickly the
minute you sell your soul for the
almighty dollar you just become like
your slave masters in China they're just
behaving like the Chinese government and
Golden State Warriors coach Steve Kerr
same sort of issue finally a reporter
was able to get to him and the apparatus
of the NBA weren't able to hustle the
reporter away and so he was asked about
this listen to the kind of weaselly
nonresponse he gets really bizarre
international story
a lot of us don't know what to make them
it's something I'm reading about just
like everybody is but I'm not going to
comment oh my gosh it's not a bizarre
international story you have good people
in Hong Kong and bad people in China and
the bad people in China are trying to
ruin the good people in Hong Kong and
we're talking about not a complicated
issue we're talking about an issue
that's been clear for at least a hundred
years and the only reason you're
pretending that it's not clear is
because you are afraid of losing your
job with the NBA President Trump the
ironic voice of moral clarity people you
know people go after him because he's
engaged in highly publicized immoral
behavior like extramarital affairs and
multiple marriages and all this kind of
stuff and you know he's mean to people
and he says mean things and sure oh
that's true but when the rubber meets
the road when it comes to important
public issues this guy has an uncommon
moral clarity and you see it here as the
NBA capitulates is so much of America
capitulates this guy president Trump
puts the issue into stark relief well
the NBA is a different thing I mean I
watch this guy Steve Kerr and he was
like a little boy he was so scared to be
even answering the question he couldn't
answer the question he was shaking oh oh
I don't know I don't know he didn't know
how to answer the question and he'll
talk about the United States very badly
I watched Popovich sort of the same
thing but he didn't look quite as scared
actually but they talked badly about the
United States but when it talks about
China they don't want to say anything
bad I thought it was pretty sad actually
it'll be it'll be very it'll be very
interesting excuse me are you okay then
with the Chinese government pressuring
the NBA over Hong Kong they have to work
out their own situation embiez they know
what they're doing but I watch the way
that like Kerr Popovich and some of the
others were pandering to China and yet
to our own country they don't it's like
they don't respect it it's like they
don't respect it I said what a
difference is that said it's very sad to
me it's very sad this is the irony this
is the real irony you have American
professional sports teams that are
encouraging people to denigrate their
own country the greatest country
in the history of the world that's not a
statement of preference that's an
objective fact the most just the most
equitable the most free the most
prosperous the most generous country in
the history of the world and they
denigrate it day by day by day and I'm
speaking most specifically of the NFL
but other teams as well other teams in
other leagues as well and yet they bend
over backwards they bend over a lot of
different ways for communist China
no one can tolerate any disrespect for
Communist China and it's not just the
NBA it's all over corporate America
Apple Apple is now censored the Taiwan
flag emoji in Hong Kong and Macau
they've censored a Hong Kong protest map
on their App Store they gave away iCloud
data and encryption keys to China all
because Apple needs China needs China to
manufacture their products needs China
to buy their products Activision
Activision Blizzard video game banned a
player for supporting the Hong Kong
protests confiscated all of his winnings
there's actually a great one reddit
right now actually reddit is a little
bit in the pocket of China too so
they're probably gonna take this this
down pretty soon but there's a great
list of all of these on reddit just a
few vans that the shoe company censored
a pro Hong Kong democracy design in its
xu disney and ESPN may be the worst
offenders band any mention of Chinese
politics related to this NBA issue
Viacom and paramount censored the Taiwan
flag that should be on Tom Cruise's
jacket in the the new Top Gun movie they
just took it out Disney and Marvel
censored a Tibetan monk from from Doctor
Strange and the screenwriter admitted
the reason they censored the Tibetan
monk is because they want to make money
out of China Marriott the hotel company
apologized to China changed Taiwan as
its listing for hotels to Taiwan China
Taiwan is not China Taiwan is separate
from the main Chinese government Taiwan
was the stronghold of nationalist China
after the Communist revolution there
other companies Mercedes virtually every
American airline OD is our ray-ban
Sheraton Princeton University JP Morgan
lots of others all censoring themselves
for China US government does it too I
remember I was working on a presidential
campaign we were talking to some
candidates
and one of the big issues then was
whether or not to label China a currency
manipulator now now we're getting tough
with China but back in 2010 2011 2012 we
weren't getting tough with China and a
lot of candidates wanted to back off
labeling China currency manipulator and
they said well look if we label China
currency manipulator they could say some
things about us and let's not forget
they're our largest creditor so you got
to be really careful and we need them
for our manufacturing and it all gets
down to the point that he who pays the
piper calls the tune this is the problem
we thought we went around for so long
and thought how great look at all these
cheap Chinese goods this is theirs this
is all upside no downside oh look at our
access to these huge Chinese markets for
our own products and our own
entertainment and our own Hollywood
movies oh there's all upside no downside
there is downside look at all this money
that's coming in from China buying up
all of our debt largest creditor funding
whatever we want to do around the world
funding our unsustainable entitlement
programs all upside no downside there is
downside there is no such thing as a
free lunch he who pays the piper calls
the tune and it's so insidious you see
it in a small scale in the media when
you when you go on media platforms if
you say things that the people who are
putting you on that platform don't like
I'll kick you off they'll throw you out
of there it's not politically correct
this is what the Left uses to completely
transform the culture and there's no
greater example of the left than a
communist government the most successful
communist government in history China
and what they do is they say look here's
all this money here's all this success
here's all this wonderful stuff we would
prefer if you don't criticize what we're
doing in Hong Kong you wouldn't mind
doing that for us would you were giving
you a billion viewers they wouldn't mind
we're giving you all this money all
these cheap goods at UK come on do us if
we did you a favor it's like the mob
it's like when you ask Don Corleone II
for a favor and he goes huh I'll grant
you this favor and one day and that day
may never come I will call upon you
to return my favor and that's what's
happening that's what we're seeing now
this is an argument for nationalism this
is an argument for maybe doing some of
our own manufacturing this is an
argument for patriotism and it gets down
to the central debate of the Trump era
that we were talking about yesterday
which is nationalism versus some other
form of government call it imperialism
because in this totally globalized world
you're not allowed to stand for very
much you're not allowed to stand for
very much because in this totally
globalized world China gets to say we
have a different country than China we
have a different system of not just
economics but a different system of
politics different belief system
different religion different culture all
that in the globalised one world kumbaya
version those distinctions go away
everything that matters to us everything
that makes us a people everything that
makes us a nation disappears another our
it plays in so perfectly to these
questions of the Trump era and what's
going to happen our international
corporations and the the people who have
no care for our own country and just
want to live all together in one world
are they gonna win or are we gonna say
something's more important than money
and we know that everything has a cost
and we're willing to pay the cost for
our for our own integrity what side is
it gonna be I'm not terribly optimistic
but I at least do have hope in the
American people and you see that a
little bit in the push back pretty much
the only guys who stood firm on this
we're Trey Parker and Matt Stone from
South Park they did a version of this on
their show they gave an answer to this
even as the Washington Wizards are
literally confiscating free Hong Kong
protest signs from their games South
Park goes out there and has Disney sort
of corporate America in the person of
Mickey Mouse going out and demanding
that we get on our knees and pay fealty
to Communist China
whoa [ __ ] they had permission to say
anything critical Chinese politics well
it is true sir the Chinese seem to
exploit their own people with forced
labor that's it shut the F up Thor
nobody gang criticize China we are
Disney and at the political level
President Trump is speaking at all of us
should speak out too moving on to a
story and another surprising story never
thought I'd have to do this I kind of
have to defend Matt Lauer I don't want
to do that because Matt Lauer is a
degenerate and I'm certainly not
defending everything he did but it seems
like there's an unfair attack against
him now in Ronin Pharaoh's new book
running Pharaoh the leading journalists
of the me2 movement he's got a new book
catch and kill he runs the story of a
former NBC producer Brooke nevels who
says that Matt Lauer raped and sodomized
her this is and they're using the word
rape to report all of this Matt Lauer
disputes this he says that he engaged in
a months-long consensual extramarital
affair with nevels what really happened
here is what everyone agrees on here's
what everyone agrees on Ronan Farrow
nevile's and Lauer they agree that at
the 2014 Sochi Olympics this young
producer Brooke nevels went out with
Matt Lauer and they drank a lot of booze
and then after a night of drinking she
went up to his hotel room he didn't
follow her back to her hotel room she
went up to his hotel room at that point
they consensually everyone agrees on
this they consensually engaged in oral
sex regular sex and what I will call
irregular sex think listen this is a
family show so let's read in between the
lines here they engaged in those three
things
consensually and oral sex consensually
in regular sex then there is a question
but what they still both agree on is
that during the irregular sex Matt Lauer
asked nevels if she liked it and she
said yes she liked it then after the
Sochi Olympics they continued their
affair at bars and at Matt Lauer's
apartment in New York for several months
here's where the story is diverge gets
to the irregular sexes sorry that that
images in your mind
says that after the oral and the regular
sex she didn't want to do the other
thing and she said she didn't want to do
the other thing but eventually she
relented and then they did the other
thing and then she said that she liked
it
Lauer says that he never forced anything
on her and it certainly wasn't an
assault then they continued the affair
consensually is what Lauer says and what
she says is they did continue the affair
but she only did it because he was a
powerful guy at the company and she
wanted to please him and appease him I
suspect all of this is true
I suspect all of that is true everything
that they are both saying about the
actual incident and the incidents that
followed I bet all of that is true what
is not true is is that that's rape it's
awful it's awful Matt Lauer is a
degenerate which is what this girl is
describing is sorted and disgusting but
what she's describing but what Ronan
Farrow is describing is not rape it's
bad but it's not rape to begin actually
on both of them mostly on him what
they're doing is very bad I mean he's
the man he's the older guy he's the more
powerful guy so he shouldn't take a
young girl up to his room also young
women should not go up to the hotel room
of married men after a night of drinking
young women are not you know totally
senseless creatures okay they have will
they have intellect they have their own
free will and their own free choices
young women shouldn't do that he's in
the position of power here so it's
mostly on him he shouldn't have asked
her to do that particular sex act he
shouldn't have Esther to have sex at all
cuz he was married and he shouldn't be
such a degenerate and he should have
lost his job anywhere else in America
right now you do what he did
totally consensually you would lose your
job and he should have lost his job too
but that isn't rape and the reason this
matters is because rape is a very
serious crime and rape does happen a lot
and it should be treated very seriously
and when we treat otherwise consensual
months-long extramarital affairs as
being the same thing as sexual assault
and rape you
downplay the seriousness of rape you
undermine actual victims of rape and
that's a very bad thing and the the me
to this has always been the tension of
the me2 movement is the me2 movement is
exposing actual bad things being done by
actual bad people in serious positions
in Hollywood but at the same time there
is a risk of redefining rape and sexual
assault so broadly that you actually
diminish the seriousness with which we
as a culture treat rape that would be a
very bad thing to do I have no desire
ever to defend Matt Lauer again I think
he's a complete dirtbag so please please
me to movement don't make me have to
even remotely in any way defend what he
is saying because he's pushed back very
hard against this and he actually has
acknowledged some of his own moral
wrongdoing here not sufficiently but a
little bit but what he's saying is I
should have been more open from the very
beginning I was a rich powerful famous
guy and I took advantage of my position
and I had extramarital affairs with
young women but I didn't rape anybody
and maybe he did in other circumstances
I don't know if he did or not but in
what everyone is describing here that is
not yet there is so much more to get to
but unfortunately we have to take a
break and head on over to Daley wire.com
because we've got the mailbag coming up
and if you go to Daley wire here's the
important thing you get me you get the
end replevin sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the amount wall
show you get all of the attached
questions in mailbag but you get another
Kingdom and another Kingdom is super
cool and the new episodes are dropping
on Monday but for subscribers you get to
listen to them on Friday and that is
going to be tomorrow and actually
tomorrow when this episode drops drew
and I are going to be doing a discussion
for all access members at 3 p.m. Eastern
noon Pacific so head on over there it's
gonna be a lot of fun listen to another
Kingdom and you and and you can also do
it by the way on The Daily wire app the
long waited app is finally here it's
fantastic and subscribers can access all
of our content articles shows and more
straight from the app so head on over do
that and make sure you get your leftist
ears tumblr you're gonna need it we'll
be right back with the mailbag
all right let's get into the mailbag I
always run so late in the mailbag so
let's try to go right in from Arun dear
a doctor koop fa I have never boycotted
a business or individual on the basis of
politics however in the past few days
various events such as Robert DeNiro
cursing on CNN due to his hatred of the
president and the vegan restaurants in
my city tweeting support for
pseudo-scientific climate alarmism what
is the point at which we should refuse
to purchase goods or entertainment from
extreme liberals Thanks love to show
these are actually different questions
one is about boycotts one is about your
choices as a consumer they're related
they seem very similar but they're
actually different a boycott is when you
organize enough people to cause enough
pain to a business to make them change
their behavior I think of the bus
boycotts during the civil rights
movement but weight cuts almost never
work because no one actually cares what
we see instead are fake boycotts
and this is ginned up almost exclusively
on the left by groups like Media Matters
and sleeping giants and those kind of
people to get 30 or 40 people to call up
a conservative media personality
sponsors and convince them that there's
a boycott and have them drop them right
away out of fear of some future problem
but it's only ever 30 or 40 people it
doesn't in any way affect the bottom
line so boycotts don't work I don't
think conservatives really should engage
in boycotts it's it's unless we're
talking about some seriously momentous
political issue personal consumer choice
is a different thing I won't purchase
anything from Nike not that I ever did
purchase very much from Nike I'm not
exactly the sneaker wearing type but I
certainly won't purchase anything from
Nike anymore why because Nike didn't
just weigh in on some political issue
that I disagreed with they explicitly
endorsed a protest of the American flag
not just a protest of taxes or something
that or tax cuts or not a protest of
this issue of that issue the flag itself
the country itself which I pledge
allegiance to I've pledged allegiance to
the country in a way that I have
allegiance to my parents it's totally
right and just to love your country and
to
a loyalty to your country and they
undercut that so I won't shop at Nike
that's a pretty high level now other
companies do things that I don't like
and I still use them sometimes that's
just the way it is what are you gonna do
for instance some coffee companies will
match donations that employees make to
Planned Parenthood I hate that I hate
Planned Parenthood I want it to be
abolished tomorrow and if I were ever in
a position of power I would certainly do
everything I could to do that but if you
start getting down into the weeds on
every little thing huge numbers of
companies match employees donations to
Planned Parenthood that you basically
wouldn't be able to participate in the
market if you were to make your
decisions that way and life is too short
and there are too many details involved
so the answer that I will give you on on
the consumer choice aspect of this is
the answer that Antonin Scalia actually
gave me when we were asking him about
how about sort of particular issues of
constitutional law like story decisis
and gun control and what that really
means how should you make those
decisions
it's an unsatisfying answer but it's the
real one very carefully from Annie do
you think this next election no matter
the result will create even more divide
between the Democrats and Republicans
yes yes it will create more divide and
it will acknowledge that there is more
of a divide being created a divide among
Democrats and Republicans by the way is
not necessarily a bad thing I actually
think it's nice that the parties are
different
I want a choice not an echo like Phyllis
Schlafly and Barry Goldwater in the
early post-war conservative movement
used to talk about I want there to be a
difference too often you elect a
Republican and he behaves just like a
Democrat so I want that divided
perspective ideological divide
philosophical divide I want that to be
stark and clear because what that gives
us is honesty now I don't want there to
be a divide among countrymen who view
each other as alien and awful and
terrible and deplorable and irredeemable
you see that a little bit from the way
the right looks at the left a little bit
you mostly see it from the way the left
looks at the right there's no moral
equivalence here I mean Hillary Clinton
the 2016 Democratic presidential nominee
said that half of her country
or deplorable and irredeemable that is
pretty clear you don't hear that kind of
stuff from President Trump you don't
hear that kind of stuff from the right
generally so I don't want that divided
to grow but that divide is not going to
be caused by a presidential election
that's not gonna be cured by a
presidential election because that
divide is not political in the strict
sense its cultural and its religious if
you as Cardinal Manning said all
political debates are fundamentally
theological debates if you approach
politics from the position that man is
broken we are fallen we are all
deserving of death we all do terrible
terrible things and we can accept the
grace of God and the mercy of God and if
we forgive other people's trespasses as
our trespasses are forgiven us and we
pray for mercy and mercy is a category
of godliness then you can look on your
countrymen with whom you disagree and
whose goals you oppose with a degree of
charity and with a degree of patriotism
with a degree of brotherliness as your
fellow citizens if you approach politics
as nothing in the world makes any sense
and there's no such thing as Redemption
and we all just take a dirt nap and turn
to worm food when we die and it's just a
brutal fight until the end you can't you
can't look at it that way you'll hate
your fellow countryman I mean you'll do
anything they get they get twisted so
out of proportion when the when leftists
look at things like this that problem
will not be solved by an election that
problem will be solved culturally and
ultimately religiously and it president
Trump is capable of doing a lot of
things I think that's a little beyond
his purview from Grant my girlfriend of
four years and I broke up last night she
she broke up with you I did she broke up
with me we've had some trouble for the
last three months she might not want
kids
she isn't aligned with my Christian
faith she's an incredibly sweet girl and
I planned my life with her but now it
all seems all for nothing do I fight for
her or do you believe a couple should
share religious views to truly work this
is a question that depends on a lot of
variables that you haven't given me most
especially your age
sweet Elise and I dated for the first
go-around when we were like children we
met when we were 10 we dated in high
school we had very different views not
really from each other even their
different views than what we hold now on
all manner of questions from politics
culture religion and so that changes
over time and you grow with someone or
you grow apart from someone now by the
time we got married
those things started to converge
obviously I mean you're not going to
have completely different views from
your spouse about how the world works
when you say she's not aligned with your
Christian views what does that mean
could she come around is she sort of
curious or is she totally antagonistic
to those views that's a big distinction
she says she might not want kids tissue
she really not want kids or she does
that just the sort of thing that a 18
year old millennial or gen z girl says
it's a big difference to if faith is
very important and your faith will
dictate a lot of other things that
happen in your family certainly you
shouldn't marry a girl who says
explicitly I don't want kids if you want
kids that is a recipe for disaster
and certainly you shouldn't marry a girl
who says I'm never going to come around
to Christianity I won't raise the kids
Christian and we won't day like no way
that's not gonna work if that is the
case if this is real if that those are
real divides plenty of fish in the sea
my man be a man take take the dumping
for what it is or take the break-up for
what it is and move on it's not always
the manly thing to fight for the girl if
it's really not going to work
move on that's the manly thing to do if
these are all soft nose and not quite
and you have this more of a leadership
role here yeah I might be worth fighting
for but it's it's really about the
relationship it's not about hard and
fast rules it's not about a checklist
it's not some kind of clinical
relationship it's it's about love and
your future together and your ability to
lead a family from Dan what is your
impression on China's reaction of
blocking all South Park materials from
Chinese social media South Park could
receive no higher honor than being
blocked from Chinese social media that
is truly a badge of honor Matt Stone and
Trey Parker should be very very
out of themselves you see an analogue to
this in American politics there are some
conservatives who when they get
criticized by left-wing media the New
York Times Washington Post NBC CNN they
get really sad they're really nervous
they want to fix it they want to get
better or they know please take me back
those guys are the worst there is no
greater badge of honor than for CNN and
the Washington Post and Media Matters
and all those truly truly troubled
people with very wrong views of the
world to come after you that's a good
thing it shows you're doing something
right from Elliott what is your opinion
on what California should do about the
homeless crisis if you were the governor
of California what would be the first
thing you would do to combat
homelessness the first thing I would do
is stop permitting it I would not permit
it now this question comes down to
mayors of cities some mayor of LA or
mayor of San Francisco for instance I
would not allow it to happen I would
send in the police and I would have the
police pick up all of these people and I
would have them drag the people to
homeless shelters and then if they don't
go to the homeless shelter because they
want to stay out on the street and they
want to do illegal drugs and they want
to live a vagrant life then I would have
those police come and arrest the people
and throw them in prison if the problem
is that there aren't enough homeless
shelters I would build more homeless
shelters at public expense if the
problem is that the people are crazy
they have mental problems which is true
of huge numbers of people who are
homeless on the streets then I would
build more mental asylums and what I
would do is change the law to make it
easier to involuntarily commit people
because those in insane asylums were
ripped down 50 years ago in the
misguided but understandable hope that
people didn't need to be locked up in
these institutions anymore and
psychiatric drugs would be able to cure
people and they'd be fine turns out that
when people leave the institutions and
they don't have a social network and
they don't have families and they don't
have strong communities they end up on
the street and they stop taking their
drugs and that is not
passionate to anybody sleeping on the
street is a dysfunctional act that harms
the individual and it harms society and
so I would immediately do those three
things I would make it illegal and
empower the cops to deal with it
I would make sure that there are
sufficient homeless shelters and
resources available that the people who
actually want them can use them and I
would make it easier to commit mentally
insane people to asylums those three
things they're not all politically
correct but they would do a lot to fix
the problem and in the long run they are
far far more compassionate than letting
poor vulnerable people languish on the
street from Dom in this Internet age
where we continue to further isolate
ourselves from each other how can we
come together like we used to without
compromising truth by that I mean how
people have devolved to the point where
they only see their truth instead of the
truth how can we bridge that divide
that's not a social media problem social
media exacerbates the problem but it's
not caused by social media that is a
problem of politics a problem of cost
you're in a problem at truly of religion
I mean this comes down to the the
fundamental question is there a such
thing as reality or is reality only in
the mind and for the last half century
at least and really this is a problem
that's been growing for 500 years the
West has lost faith in objective reality
and specifically in objective
metaphysical reality the moral order and
so everything just becomes a matter of
preference social media amplifies this
problem because social media makes
everybody a star everybody's their own
little celebrity and celebrities are the
worst people on earth so it exacerbates
all of their worst qualities their
hubris their pride their arrogance it
actually exacerbates ignorance because
it locks you into these tiny little
bubbles and tiny little clusters where
only your opinions are affirmed and you
never hear different points of view so
the the hope assure it'd be good if we
could reform social media in such a way
that we stop making such little
celebrity monsters but the greater hope
is addressing the philosophical and
religious issue which
is getting people to stop believing the
silly stupid lie of moral relativism of
radical subjectivism Pope Benedict the
sixteenth is wrote eloquently about this
yes Lewis wrote eloquently about this
this is the great challenge of our age
is this poison of subjectivism we need
to show people the truth there is such a
thing as truth and one simple way to do
it is to show people that there's a
difference between a fact and an opinion
and preference so fat right now what
people think is that facts and opinions
are different because facts are either
true or false and opinions are neither
true nor false they're just you know up
to preference and taste that isn't true
facts can be true or false opinions can
be true or false as well two plus two
equals four that's a fact
I think two plus two equals four that's
an opinion it happens to be a correct
opinion if I said I think two plus two
equals five that would also be an
opinion but that would be an incorrect
opinion and then if I say that I like
chocolate ice cream more than vanilla
ice cream that's a preference opinions
and preferences are different things if
you can show people that there are true
opinions it will give them confidence
not just in their own opinions it'll
give them confidence that there is an
objective reality itself and then they
can tweet about that and and fix social
media for us final question from Jake
does your sweet little ELISA know about
the humorous yet hopefully not accurate
impression you do of her on your show
shut up Mac shut your mouth Mac or was
that was that did sweet little Lisa even
hear that question I don't know no of
Cour the answer is of course no because
why would she ever listen to this show
it would be totally crazy that's our
show thank you very much I'm Michael
noses the Michael Noel's show have a
good weekend see you I'll see you in the
another Kingdom discussion tomorrow and
then I'll see on Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key
edited by Danny D'Amico audio is mixed
by Mike core Amina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20:19 if you prefer
facts over feelings if you aren't
offended by the brutal truth if you can
still laugh at the nuttiness filling our
national news cycle well tune on into
the ben shapiro show or you'll get a
whole lot of that and much more we'll
see you there